for me this idea of compromises I don't
want to do this while I'll do it for you
because I love you no no no no that is
not love that is fear and what will
happen
it will then become a transaction I'll
start to my mind will begin to tally up
but you know I gave up this for you and
I compromised here and I compromise
there and I compromise there and then
I'll say well how much are you
compromising
I feel like I'm doing all the
compromising the relationship and you're
just doing what you want to do and it
levels it as a transaction
and where there is it where there is
transaction there is no love and where
there is love there is no transaction so
it's less like you know if you're saying
to me hey Ali I I really don't like it
when you wear trainers rather than you
know I prefer you to wear smart shoes at
that point it compromise would mean for
me to be like
all right well I guess I guess I should
wear smarter shoes because that's what
that's what you want but a choice would
be okay I understand the context I'm
coming from from a place of love
I understand the effect that my trainers
have on your psyche and I know that
you're working on controlling that for
yourself
but actually I can choose to make the
choice that to me wearing trainers is
not something I'm particularly wedded to
it's not something that's like such a
fundamental part of my being that it
feels like it's it feels like I'm
compromising my true self I'm making the
choice to wear brokes rather than
trainers
is that the kind of mindset shift we're
talking about love could also be
I understand that that hurts you
but I love these trainers and I feel
comfortable in these trainers and it
wouldn't honestly it doesn't feel right
me changing the way I drive to for you
to feel happy and this is actually me
and if if my trainers I love the example
if my trainers are creating that much
pain and upset for you then maybe we
need to look at this
because I actually
don't think this is a change that I want
to make
and it's not because I don't love you
and it's not because I don't respect you
it's because it doesn't feel right to me
to begin to change in that way
and then you see where it goes the thing
about
this compromise I've seen so many times
is that we have to be careful that we
don't begin to start to make all these
small little changes yeah for the other
person
because we're afraid it would create
conflict
because if you were truly living
in line with your truth
and this person ends up getting
triggered and upset
we'll figure out really quite quickly
whether or not this is working yeah
I had you know an example of with
countless but one comes to mind where
we're looking and seeing how uh
one of my clients had changed over time
during the relationship and the the
marriage had ended up in
in uh in adultery and collapsing
and what we identified is that yes but
if I hadn't if I had been true to myself
she would have got upset yeah okay how
often would that have happened every day
really every day how many times like
literally 10 15 times a day if I'm like
so if you lived if you had lived true to
yourself from when you met her 10 15
times a day she would have got upset and
angry yes how long would that
relationship have lasted for
a week yeah two weeks
You're Gonna Learn very very quickly
it's not working out instead of what
three years five years ten years
and then you realize actually whenever I
am truly myself
there is no acceptance and love and
appreciation instead there's just
hurt and upset and conflict hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye